millions of people are braving the
freezing temperatures in New York to
watch the Thanksgiving Day Parade in
person they're hoping it won't be too
windy for those iconic balloons to fly
59 balloons are ready to dazzle the
crowd the tallest guys is 62 feet high
that's around six stories entertainment
tonight's Kevin Frazier and Kelty Knight
are up early to bring you all of the
action they will be hosting the
Thanksgiving Day Parade on CBS guys good
morning
good to see you Happy Thanksgiving hey
of Vlad Alex and bianna it is a little
chilly out here like 21 degrees right
now feels like 12 yeah feels like 12
degrees this could be one of the coldest
Thanksgivings on record the weather
really is the big deal it's not because
of how cold it is it's all about the
winds and weather those balloons you
just mentioned will fly or not here's
the deal if a sustained wind gets up
above 24 miles per hour then they're
gonna pull the balloons down or if the
wind gusts get up above 34 then they
will pull the balloons down it's a
game-time decision the NYPD and the
parade folks will make that decision
right up and they will wait right up
until the last second as of now we're
under the threshold so we're good and
we're hoping that the balloons will fly
and if they fly it'll be fantastic yeah
and the winds definitely have been
picking up this morning as we've been
sitting out here but if they do fly we
have a new addition to the parade this
year Goku Dragon Ball super Broly he is
new at the spiky hair any one of the
fans of that show and comic will
recognize him right away he is going to
be joining us for the first time as well
as some big stars Diana Ross Ashley
Tisdale John Legend Rita Ora and we have
on our show some of the biggest
performance from Broadway King Kong dear
Evan Hanson
we're so excited to bring that all to
you in just a few minutes we have faith
that we will be seeing them Kevin and
Kelty I know the thought bubbles that
you must be having right now and that is
the West Coast is the Best Coast this
morning but can you tell us about the
crowds or how many people are coming out
to brave this weather you know what's
funny is earlier this morning and
usually
we walk over about 5:00 a.m. the streets
are crowded they're packed they were
kind of empty when we came over but now
the crowds are starting to fill out
people wait a little bit longer they put
on a few extra layers but the crowds are
out here they expect 3.5 million people
to line the streets of New York and you
see their strength in numbers packed
tight and put on layers and then you'll
be okay and everybody is hanging tough
look no matter how cold it is you cannot
dampen the spirit of Thanksgiving this
parade you just can't mess with it
absolutely not blankets seem to be the
new fashion accessory of the parade this
year because we put one on before we
start the route Kevin this is your
eighth year working the parade Keltie
it's your fourth you guys are basically
veterans of this parade what lessons
have you learned and what are you most
looking forward to this year well I
would say that the thing I always look
forward to is when the balloons come
down six Avenue they come so close and
it blows your mind each and every time
every time we turn around it's like oh
my goodness look at these things and so
that is my favorite thing and so that's
why I think it's always important if
you're coming to the parade get out
early layer up and get a good spot so
you can feel the how big the balloons
are you can just feel them walk right by
you it is unbelievable for me it's seen
the performers the cheerleaders and the
dancers and the musicians you know these
bands they fundraise all year it's a
lifelong dream of them to come and you
know come to the parade and perform it's
such an honor and to see their dreams
come true
that energy is infectious and it's so
heartwarming and by the way when you
look down here you see people holding
signs from Alabama South Carolina Alaska
other countries so people have come from
all over the world to fulfill a lifelong
dream of being out here and enjoying the
parade a little cold ankle to hurt and
Kelty still very fashionable as a great
listen she's from Edmonton this is
basically summer for you guys
guys we're looking forward to watching
you yeah and Dragon Ball Z's all good
Kevin but you know what we talked about
yesterday underdog you supposed to
report back to me let me know if you see
underdog nobody else here knows them
thank you guys I can't believe people
don't no wonder we do have so does
America right thank you very much you
can catch the Thanksgiving Day Parade
right here on CBS thanks guys